Today I am meeting with
Fernanda for the first time.
And today I am talking not so much
just about language learning, but
about this international community
that's forming around language around
people's interests in connecting with
people from other parts of the world.
And I was introduced to Fernanda
by Ebrahim of Egypt who follows
me on Twitter and who pointed out
that Fernanda has a book club and
a podcast about her book club.
And she was going to be...
in her book club they were going to
be discussing my book where I talk
about my experience learning languages.
So I thought it would be very
interesting to chat with Fernanda.
And before I get going, I just want
to remind you that if you enjoy
these videos, please subscribe,
click on the bell for notifications.
If you follow us on, uh, on
Spotify or some other podcast
service, please leave a review.
Okay.
Fernanda...
NIce to meet you.
I'm so happy to be here.
I'm thankful uh, To meet you.
Not, not at all.
I thought it was such an interesting
story because it has to do
with books, with reading, with
language, with people connecting.
So first of all, Ebrahim lives
in Egypt and he suggested I check
out your, uh, uh, blog or podcast.
And what connected you with
Ebrahim in the first place?
Can you explain the background?
Yes, we are, uh, Effortless English
members and we have AJ as a coach and
we have a great community, great, uh,
international community with people
from all of the world, I'm Brazilian.
Ebrahim from Egypt too.
We have friends from France,
Italy, Germany, Serbia, India, a
lot of people, and we have a great
relationship in this community.
I should point out for those who don't
know that AJ Hoge of Effortless English,
is a tremendous, uh, teacher of English.
He teaches by actually helping people
learn rather than speaking things at them.
So he's very much, I mean, I'm, I
know AJ personally, I've met with
him and I'm a great supporter of,
of what he does to bring people
together around learning English.
What prompted you to start
a book club, and to start a
podcast about your book club?
Yes, it's actually, it's not a book club.
We have a book club from our group, but
I start edto, to do these podcasts and
I combined books and languages because I
love learning languages and I love books.
And...
books are great resource to acquire
vocabulary, to have fun learning
and have fun, um, at the same time.
It's so grateful and I chose your book as
the first one, because I love your book.
This book inspired me a
lot when I first read it.
Uh, when I first read your
book, I just read twice and
now I'm reading it in French.
And when I first read, I, I think to
myself, oh my gosh, I'm a linguist because
you said everyone can be a linguist.
Yes.
And you, you, you don't have a, to
be intellectual or a great, great uh,
academic person to acquire a second
language to learn a second language.
I think, I think it's so great.
One thing I should point out
because I always get criticism
for using the word linguist to
describe someone speaking languages.
In most other languages the
word is polyglot, whatever.
But in English, if you look up the
dictionary, the first meaning of language
is someone who speaks several languages
because after all linguistics came along
later, but the word linguist is at least
500 years old and it describes someone who
learns and who speaks several languages.
And I wrote my book.
Uh, you know, uh, where I, I
can't remember the name of the
book, what's it called again?
The Way of the Linguist.
And at that time I was unaware of the
name of the word polyglot and, uh, to
most English speakers "linguist" is
someone who speaks several languages.
Uh, it's a problem when we translate
the book, because then we can't
really use the word linguist because
in other languages, linguist, that
means someone who studies linguistics.
Uh, but that...
I wrote that book in 2003.
At that time I spoke nine languages.
Uh, and I described my own
experience and, and yeah.
I encourage people to learn
languages and, uh, hopefully it,
it, uh, it achieves that, you know?
Anyone can do it, but...
So you're, you have the,
uh, explain your book...
so you do have a book club?
Uh, we have a book club in our group...
but in Effortless English?
No, no, just from internet.
We gather.
Yes.
We gather to, eh, uh, all of,
all of us and we discuss, we,
we discuss every meeting, we
discuss one chapter of the book.
We read this book during this week
and we discuss, we, we schedule a time
to discuss this chapter of the book.
So again, to be clear, so this is all.
And these are non-native
speakers of English.
So these are people who are learning
English and you choose a book and then
you schedule a Zoom conference and then
people come on and you might read a
part of the book and discuss the book.
And typically how many people
show up for these meetings?
We had, today in the morning and we are
7, 7, 7 people, and each one discuss.
One person makes a little summary of
the chapter and the others discuss.
The ideas, and all of this in English,
because English is our common language.
I speak Portuguese, one friend French.
Another one speaks Hindu.
Yes.
And, uh, and so on.
So do you have any native speakers
there, like does AJ participate
or is it, it's all learners?
All learners.
Great idea.
We could do that with other languages too.
Uh, yeah, absolutely.
I have a book.
Um, in my French group, another
one, another one is my French
group, just with Brazilian people
that, that are learning French.
And, and so does this, for example,
is there an organization, or is there
a website or for example, the French
group, uh, how does it get together?
How do you connect with the other members?
Oh, it also zoom.
We use zoom and we send a link.
Everyone joins us, joins in these
meetings and we discuss the book.
how do you recruit the members?
How do you find members?
Oh, I get engaged in an academy,
French academy in Brazil and for
English we get together from AJ.
Okay.
Yes, we, we meet each other in
Twitter first, but now we have, AJ
has a group in Gab, Gab, Gab.com.
Yes.
All right.
Very interesting.
And, but you also have a podcast
because, uh, Ebraheem sent
me a link to your podcast.
I went and
checked it out and it was very
nice, like a very nice landing
page and a very, very well done.
So, so can you give me some
background background on the podcast
and what, what your objective is?
Um, my, the reason, the reason why I
decided to do this, eh, For, eh, it's
for my practice, English, to practice
my English, and improve my English to
be able to speak more fluently because
sometimes I forget the words that I
want to say and making the podcast I
can, I can prepare something carefully.
I can read the thing I can
speak to you spontaneously also.
And I think I will improve.
I have friends in our group from
Effortless English, neighbors
that have also a podcast.
Ebraheem has a podcast, great podcast.
Well, I should look him up, you
know, it's very interesting.
So you say you're, you have the podcast
in order to improve your English.
And I am sure that as you speak with
me now, speaking in English, which is
not your native language, that there's
a certain level of anxiety that you may
not, you may miss something or you might
not be able to remember a word, yet
for me listening, I have the impression
that your English is totally natural.
It's amazing.
The difference between how we feel
about our language, wherever we're
worried, we're going to forget,
then we can't find this word.
We take another word.
We all do this, right.
We can't remember the word we want
so we takes some other word and
we are, we change our conversation
to kind of suit the words.
We're able to find a
certain level of tension.
But for me, listening to you, I
don't sense any tension whatsoever.
And so I think it's an important
message that we all, we're always
much more nervous than we should be.
And we actually do a lot
better than we think we do.
So, I mean, I feel the same
when I speak Portuguese.
I make so many mistakes.
People understand me, so
it's good enough, you know?
Uh, so I'm going to leave by the way,
I'm going to leave obviously links in
the description box to, to your podcast.
To Ebraheem's podcasts.
I'll get that information,
uh, so people can follow up.
But, uh, I just think yours was such an
interesting example to me, that Ebraheem
from Egypt suggested I talk to Fernanda
from Brazil and you were brought together
by AJ Hoge from the United States.
And you've got people there from Serbia,
from France, from India, from wherever.
And it's a wonderful sense...
I mean, to be able to connect with people
in any situation, I mean, you want to
connect with people who live near you.
For example, I mean, we are happiest
when we're connecting with others.
But now that we can connect with people
in a, in a meaningful way, it's not,
you know, personal, you can't give
a person a hug, but you can connect.
And so that's an interesting example
of how social media, which often
has a very negative effect on
society can also be very positive
and bringing people together.
Absolutley.
So where do you think your podcast will
go, what do you see as, as you're doing it
for yourself, you say, well, your English,
which is already very good, and you want
to encourage others to do the same thing?
Yes.
And I want to discuss about books.
Sometimes I'm reading a book and I
want to discuss, and I don't have
people around me to discuss it.
I want to say something
about this book with someone.
I think I will create these to
read, to read the great part
of one book I have read...
yeah.
Yeah.
Very interesting.
Well, um, I will, uh, you know, I
wish you the best, the best of luck.
I think it's a tremendous initiative.
Again, my wife and I were in Brazil.
We thoroughly enjoyed ourselves.
We didn't get to Sao Paulo, but we got
a bit of, a bit of a flavor of Brazil.
Uh, I still remember on the Copacabana,
we were sitting there having a beer.
They have these, uh, in the different, uh,
cafes where they're, they're serving beer.
They also have bands and people walk
by and they're dancing the Samba,
everybody was having a good time.
But you, you go to Salvador?
You went to Salvador?
Yes.
Salvador is my, my
favorite city in Brazil...
Salvador was amazing.
Uh, there again at night we went for
a walk and again, they have bands in
the different cafes and restaurants.
So you're hearing music all over.
And we went to the old city, you know,
where they, the slave trade market was
and the old style houses and, and, uh,
it was a, it was a very interesting city.
It's, it's a different flavor, a
completely different flavor from Rio.
Uh, yeah, we walked all over.
Took taxis.
Uh, I mean, it's got its social problems.
Massive favelas in, in some follow,
but, uh, we met some people actually
LingQ members who  live in, in  favela.
So I guess it's, it's a life
that people get used to.
And, uh, that's what it is.
They managa.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well, thank you very much, Fernanda,
a lot of fun, and I'm sure that my
viewers will enjoy finding out about
your podcast and your book club.